Hi, everyone. Seth MacFarlane
here and I am thrilled to share
the trailer for our new
Peacock original series, ted.
Telling the story of Ted and
John’s early days.
Let’s take a look.
Hey Johnny?
How bad is
school gonna suck?
You’re not gonna like it.
How bad?
Well, it’s like getting your nuts
smashed together so hard they
become just one nut.
Holy shit.
You should be going to school
every day with John.
Ah, no thanks.
You might have fun!
No, I would not have fun.
I guard the house when you
guys are out.
What happened to the TV?
It was an accident.
You’re going to school and
you’re going to grow a
fucking brain!
Oh come on!
Hey dork,
are you bringing your dolls
to school?
It’s the nineties,
times are changing.
Sexual Education.
Let’s start
with masturbation.
If you’re going to
assign homework,
Johnny already
did it this morning.
Hey, shut the fuck up dude!
I haven’t smoked, I haven’t had
sex, I haven’t had a girlfriend.
I’m a loser.
You and me have been best
friends like our whole lives.
We’re about to get high
for the first time.
Can we have drugs, please?
Let’s do this right.
Ah, man!
Can you guys believe we’re like
having an experience,
and experiencing reality?
Is there a fucking gas leak
or something?
Nice costume, fuck-face!
It’s possible that the two of you
might not be total screw-ups.
Take a long look,
this is what life is.
Oh shit Teddy, I’m the last
virgin in school.
We can fix this.
We gotta find a buyer.
Fresh penis!
Get your fresh penis here!
Teddy, Jesus Christ!
Still has that new penis smell.
Would you shut up!
Alright, I’m just trying to help.